at the chaos economy uh and finally i
know this looks totally random but why
we need better maps
and hopefully all of these slightly odd
uh different strands of ideas will will
intertwine uh in the next 10 minutes or
so and you'll see what on earth i'm
going on about um first of all the
problem with data so you know i i am not
just economics but data editor uh and so
i spend a lot of time looking at numbers
uh i love numbers i love charts
but you know we've also got to be aware
that you know when people look at
numbers when they present data
often there's a sense that you've got
this kind of monolithic truth there
you've got a number therefore it must be
true and you know often data often
charts can tell you something pretty
insightful i mean just this morning
we had labor market data coming out
which showed us well a few things you
had the payrolled employees that's more
or less back to where it was before the
pandemic uh began but look hours worked
across the economy so it's just looking
at total across the economy and all i've
done is i've rebased them to the start
of the pandemic here so you get the
sense of just how things have changed
versus that to where they are now hours
work not quite back to where they were
before but just look at this vacancies
i mean that is just the extraordinary
chart isn't it showing you
part of what perhaps you're seeing in
the labor market at the moment the fact
that vacancies are at the highest level
they've ever been this is just looking
relative to the last uh to the start of
the pandemic start of january last year
but nonetheless that level is also the
highest it's ever been and that's part
of
the various different crises that we're
facing at the moment across the economy
it's not just one crisis i mean people
talk you know and you know to some
extent i think the the media is guilty
of this as well as simplifying it down
to one thing a supply shortage or a
supply crisis but actually it strikes me
you've got kind of at least four crisis
maybe more than that four crises in one
you've got an energy crisis so you know
we all know about that at the moment
prices up to extraordinary levels a
distribution crisis so getting stuff
around is very difficult right now uh
you've got a labor crisis at the moment
so in terms of actually getting people
to do the work that you need to do and
then you've got a global supply crisis
and all of these things are kind of
intertwined and they they feed off into
each other but to some extent they are
four separate stories and when you look
at certain different charts of what's
going on with global prices i mean you
heard in that panel
a lot of concern about inflation right
now let me show you a chart that kind of
backs that up and i've got another one
coming up in a bit uh that we'll do so
as well this is just showing you prices
of certain key materials over the course
of the last couple of years so going
going back to april last year started
the pandemic over that period metals
prices across the world up by 77
crude oil up by 200 percent and i
updated this about a week ago so it may
have gone up since then food prices up
by 40 and in any kind of normal period
you know 40 increase in food prices over
about 18 months would be considered
quite a lot but just look at what's
happened to shipping costs
over that period
up by 400 percent and you know these are
obviously global numbers that's from the
shanghai shipping index up by 400 over
that period
put all of that together and that all
looks really quite inflationary doesn't
it and that's you know part of the the
story that we're undergoing right now
but it underlines you know we talked
about distribution crisis well there you
can see shipping up there and then
you've got an energy crisis with crude
and then you've got this kind of global
supply crisis with other materials going
up in price as well all of that starting
to feed through into the prices that
we're paying but it takes a while to go
through that kind of chain reaction now
i said that you know there are problems
with data it doesn't tell you
definitively what's going on sometimes
for certain stories for certain charts
it is really instructive but for other
charts uh for other kind of
episodes it's not necessarily telling
you quite as definitive a story as you'd
like to the data is not always
definitive and framing matters so let me
give you an example of what i mean by
framing remember the government has
talked quite a lot recently about
statistics like this the uk is the
strongest growing economy in the world
actually well they say in the g7 and
they they pull out statistics like this
and indeed that is true if you look just
at the growth in q2
there is the uk stronger than any other
economy in the g7 but here's the thing
you know the framing of that question
really matters are you just looking at
growth in the latest quarter or are you
going to look at growth com you know
where we are now compared with the start
of the pandemic because if you do that
let's just look at that different
framing same statistics same specific
gdp different framings what happens to
that red bar
it goes down there it turns out actually
the uk is not the best in the g7
actually it's somewhere kind of mid
maybe lower table
and the us these bars are just showing
you how gdp now compares or the latest
estimate compares with the start of the
pandemic and the uk kind of down there
with germany uh and france so don't be
similar to the rest of them now
framing matters also when it comes to
some of the issues that we're trying to
wrestle with at the moment and we might
talk about this a little bit more
certainly it came up in ian's panel this
question of whether the uk is a low-wage
low-skill economy and whether that's
either problematic whether that's an
opportunity whether it's something that
we need to kind of do something about
the government talks about that a lot
about the idea of pulling us up with
higher wages to be a higher wage economy
but let's just interrogate it and ask
whether the data actually bears out that
we are
a low-wage economy these lines here all
of these bars are just showing you
different members of the oecd so
developed economies around the world and
you see the average over there and the
higher the bars are the higher you're
talking about average net income after
taxes in other words on the basis of
this
it looks like the uk is quite a
high-wage economy not a low-wage economy
because we're quite high up there
but here's the thing okay same question
again looking at whether we're a
low-wage or high-wage economy now look
at the proportion of people who are
low-paid
and this is just the higher these bars
are the more low-paid people there are
of as a proportion and the uk is high up
there
so it really depends on what question
you're asking you can ask one question
you know and you know use that previous
chart to suggest that we're actually
high wage or we could use this chart to
suggest we're quite low wage and same
thing with skills as well
this might be something that you've
encountered when it comes to you know
the skilled levels this shows you low
skilled say the proportion of the
population who have low skill levels so
below secondary education um and so the
higher the bars are perversely here the
higher the bars are the more low skilled
people there are and the uk actually has
quite a small proportion of low skilled
people so we actually have decent levels
of skills when you look across the
population
but here's the thing okay the question
is whether those skills were appropriate
for the job that someone wants to do
aren't they you know it's not
necessarily particularly useful having a
degree in one thing or indeed a
qualification in one thing when you
actually want to do another job and that
comes down to a statistic called skills
mismatch the extent to which
those skills that you have or your
applicant has are appropriate for the
job that you want them to fill
the uk has the biggest skills mismatch
or one of the biggest skills mismatch in
the developed world in other words we
have lots of very skilled people but
they're not necessarily skilled in the
particular thing that they need to be to
get the job that people want them to do
so there you know you see it's a much
more nuanced issue than i think a lot of
people imply and digging into the data
sometimes helps you to understand that
but the other problem with data is that
it's not always especially definitive
and
i'm going to show you a chart here
actually
and i wonder if you can kind of guess
what
what data we're looking at here i'll
give you a clue so it starts in 1990 it
goes to 2020.
as you can see lots of lines here
a bit of a dip there
but i don't know can anyone guess
what
what this is what on earth this
statistic is
it's a pretty it's a pretty familiar one
for all of us
because this is actually
gdp
this is looking at every sector of the
economy
and their gross domestic product gross
value added
and just to underline that we really are
talking about every sector here we've
just rebased it back to 1990 let me show
you some of these sectors so it and
communications up up is an extraordinary
amount soap and detergents i didn't
realize soap and detergents had done so
well over the past
uh few decades soft drinks up a lot
gambling there
but the point i'm trying to make is when
you know when people talk about gdp they
don't tend to talk about this
as a big picture a very complex picture
across you know 90 100 different sectors
of the economy they just focus on one
line
they focus on that line and when we're
doing a report on gdp of course we just
talk about
this line here you can see covered over
there
and we focus on that line and we tend to
ignore what's going on beneath the
surface because we've only got so much
time
but the point i want to make is that
looking beneath the surface i think is
more important now by the way we i'll
just adjust the axis there's there it is
same thing gdp but we've taken out all
of the other lines
looking beneath the surface
is more important than it's ever been
before
and i think we're starting to learn that
with these kind of
various different crises we're going
through right now
and that context is all important let me
show you what i mean about that so i'm
going to take show you gdp going all the
way back to 1300 so this is kind of
medieval gdp here and what you can see
is that for most of history for century
after century after century after
century it was basically flat it wasn't
doing much at all people were not
necessarily getting any richer because
that's you know what what gdp is
ultimately it's just the amount of
income that we're earning across the
economy and then we divide it up by the
number of people there but it just
basically wasn't doing anything and then
look what happened after kind of around
1850
it went up and up and up and up
and that really is the story of kind of
capitalism and the story of welfare and
the story of where we are today we have
got extraordinarily richer over the
course of the last 150 200 years
and typically when people talk about why
that is
they'll talk about the industrial
revolution so you might talk about
the invention of the spinning jenny and
you know mass production of cloth uh
around manchester and other places you
might talk about the bessemer process so
very relevant for where we are now about
still making uh or take it back to
abraham derby
but the reality is okay
when we look at this line and we just
have our kind of pet theories about why
it went up like that
often you know we have a tendency to
simplify and as i say i work in the
media where we need to try and explain
something quickly and that involves
simplification
but the reality is okay let's zoom in
on that line
and think about the other things that
were going on at the same time it wasn't
just steel making it wasn't just the
making of cotton it was also the
chemicals revolution so it wasn't just
industrial revolution it was chemicals
revolution where you had processes like
the leblanc process survey process
turning salt uh into chemicals saving
millions of people's lives by making the
world cleaner we didn't talk about this
all that much do we but it's incredibly
important uh today you've got uh the
invention of cement again not discussed
all that much but this is the bedrock
for the built world that we live in at
the moment and this was all happening at
the same kind of period as was the
invention of aluminium you know again
incredibly important but it was actually
relatively late that we discovered how
uh to make aluminium very energy
intensive as well uh nitrogen fixation
you know feeding the world through the
harbor bosch process i mean we've talked
quite a lot about about fertilizers
recently on the news more than we
usually do frankly um but this is a key
part again
of civilization as we know it today and
here's the thing
i'm gonna go just into the modern era
there 1947 transistors you also had
solar panels around the same kind of
time and lithium-ion batteries uh in
1985. here's the thing we're not talking
about a single industrial revolution
we're talking about various different
revolutions across all parts of the
economy
and here's another thing worth bearing
in mind every single one of those
different revolutions
involves the creation in terms of the
processes whether it's cement whether
it's the chemicals revolution whether
it's lithium-ion batteries whether it's
solar panels uh whether it's aluminium
these are all very energy intensive like
incredibly energy intensive processes
that have also involved the creation of
quite a lot of carbon
and one of the things i think hasn't
really been fully appreciated when we
talk about you know climate change
is that we need to reconsider how to
re-imagine a lot of these different
revolutions that we had that we have
achieved over over the course of the
past 200 years and it's such a big deal
it's such a big deal
and we need to talk about it a little
bit more
so let me get to that final point that i
made about why we need better maps and
what on earth i was talking about there
so i want to try and clarify that
we do a lot of talking both in sky news
in the world of economics about these
things lines
lines that show you where the gdp is
going up you saw one a moment ago lines
that show you whether inflation is going
up lines that show you whether people
are getting richer
but i think this is by the way is by a
guy called john playfair it's one of the
earliest examples of charts
and i love it so it's they're so
beautiful um but we need to do
a bit less of that
and a bit more of this
we don't talk about maps enough when it
comes to economics
and what do i mean by maps we need
better maps what do i mean by maps here
well think about
what we might be facing here so it's not
the kind of map you were expecting was
it
um
the threat of a potential bacon shortage
uh in the uk
um
what is the map behind that well there
is a kind of chain reaction isn't there
that's led to this
potential bacon shortage partly there's
the kind of labor thing we talked about
a moment ago when it comes to kind of
getting enough people to work work
within agriculture but partly it's also
this a co2 shortage so not enough co2
and why do we have not enough co2 it's
because fertilizer plants shut down and
why do fertilizers bonds shut down it's
because of record energy prices and why
do we have record energy prices well
it's because of a whole range of factors
you know not as much gas coming from
russia uh you have problems with uh with
the amount of gas that we're storing
here but also on top of that on the
other side of the world in china you've
got coal mines being shut down and some
of them being flooded recently so when i
talk about maps what i mean is this kind
of unexpected cascade this chain
reaction a chaos effect
where a butterfly wings flaps on one
side of the world and then suddenly
you're out of bacon on the other side of
the world
coal mine's shut down chain reaction all
the way through
we don't understand that stuff very well
and i you know certainly within the
world of economics but the reason that i
think it's you know quite significant
that we're here talking to you is that
we want to try and understand it better
and i think it's businesses around the
country
that work within these supply chains
that understand this stuff more
intimately certainly more intimately
than the government for whom this came
as an enormous surprise
and more intimately than most of us let
me give you one other example of another
kind of chain reaction
same thing again chinese coal mine
shutdowns
why is that going to have an impact on
semiconductors because no one really
when people talk about semiconductor
shortage they're not talking about coal
mining but they should
let me show you why
if you want semiconductors if you want
to make computer chips
you need silicon metal if you want
silicon metal you need coking coal a lot
of coking coal goes into the production
of silicon metal i need silicone metal
to make polysilicon polysilicon
to make silicon wafers and silicon
wafers to make semiconductors
this
supply chain
is not very widely understood
and yet it's incredibly important for
the way the world fits together and we
need better maps of this kind of thing
and this is what i'm talking about i'm
going to show you one more chart and
then we're going to talk to um torsten
bell who's uh who's been watching this
probably with with dismay about the idea
of having to discuss all this random
stuff but
chinese culture mine shutdowns silicon
metal this is all coming our way in
terms of semiconductor shortage right
now the shortage that we have is largely
happening within places like taiwan it's
in fabs that basically aren't able to
produce enough to kind of keep the
automobile sector supplied
but this side of things we don't talk
about enough but let me show you what's
happening to silicon metal prices so
that metal that you need coal for it's
been more or less flat for most of
recent history this goes all the way
back to 2016. but just recently
instead earlier in september there was a
production cut of silicon metal in
yunnan province in china where a lot of
this stuff is produced just look at what
happened to the silicon metal price
and that's something that's very rarely
remarked on it's something where people
aren't really putting those pieces
together
and trying to understand how that is
about to come down the road to us
but when we talk about inflation when we
talk about the state of the economy this
is the kind of thing uh that we should
be discussing so with that in mind i
mean we have a whole range of different
things we've discussed there we've
discussed the state of the uk labour
market we've discussed
the extent to which we have shortages
we've discussed what happens within
supply chains and whether we have a good
understanding of them
i want to bring in torsten bell from the
resolution foundation
who should be down the line uh from uh
westminster who i hope has been
listening to some of that
uh and i uh probably with with with some
uh trepidation uh i wanna start ashley
thorsten by asking you about that
question of the labor market the
question of you know whether we do have
a kind of low-wage low-skill economy
and kind of where we are on that
particular
path
well i mean i think there's some there's
obviously some good news in that space
ed which is you know what we learned
over the last
what have we last over the last 20 years
is that yes we have been a country with
more
low paid hourly low paid people than
most similar countries
but actually having now decided to
introduce a minimum wage at the end of
the last century and then to
aggressively ramp it up under this
government over the last
five years we've actually seen a very
big fall the first fall in low pay for
four decades and it's happened without
big losses in employment so we've
learned that the country had a problem
and that policy was able to make a very
big difference to that and that you know
these are not small fry amounts of money
for people you know even just looking at
the rise since 2016 a full-time minimum
wage worker will be well over a thousand
pounds a year better off because of that
policy change
so think so things are starting to to
improve but how about where we are now
so you've got obviously universal credit
card that is going ahead or at least the
kind of temporary up left
going uh energy price is incredibly high
right now to what extent are you seeing
the potential for real kind of pain
across the labor market and that lower
pay side of it
over the course of the next few months
well i think the whole country is set
for a difficult autumn on the cost of
living side you know everyone will know
seeing their prices going up faster than
they are
used to and obviously energy prices
partly reflecting some of what you were
saying earlier ed are obviously the the
poster boys for the the cost of living
crunch that is coming big rise just
happened last week on energy prices and
another one coming in april
then so you've got prices going up i
think the thing that is particularly bad
for low-income households is that for
them
the price going up will be accompanied
by their income going down
because of the cut to universal credit
that happened last wednesday and that
will be biting for families right across
the next the next month as their lower
benefit payments come through and we're
not talking about a small change we're
talking about a thousand pounds a year
for well over four million households on
average people losing five percent of
their income
overnight so yeah i think it is a really
tough autumn coming it's a tough autumn
for everybody because everyone has to
pay their energy bills but it's
particularly tough for lower middle
incomes households who
those
areas of spending food and energy are
particularly large amounts of their
spending and as i say for lots of them
their income is coming down too
and so since you had to sit through like
our excellent audience here had to sit
through my slightly random
set of charts about supply chains about
energy about all of these different
factors i just want to get your take uh
on that i mean you know we're living in
a world now where
these things seem to be cropping up
quite a lot
and i wonder you know does does brexit
play a part in that that's been one of
those things that's been discussed do we
do we do we have the right kind are we
looking at the right things to
understand what's coming down the line
you know i thought your um economic and
science history lesson was actually
really valuable because
one of the things
i think that we need to just understand
is modern economies are very complex
okay and in general we have spent the
last kind of 40 50 years moving away
from the idea of planning our economy
moving away from the idea that the
government does understand those supply
chains that you were drawing out and
moving towards a liberal view which is
the job of government is to provide
stability and then we should leave
individuals and firms to make those
supply chains work well because trying
to plan them is beyond uh is beyond what
is possible from sitting with a
spreadsheet in westminster and in
general obviously that's true because as
you illustrated ed there's lots of
complex interactions in supply chains
that economists aren't going to
understand and you don't have to be very
liberal to think uh that it's beyond the
width of a central planner to get it
right when it's guessing what the future
looks like so in general that's true
where that becomes difficult
is when big shocks happen
when big change happens and you saw that
in the financial crisis when everybody
who previously loved financial
innovation and complex financial
products suddenly decided that those
products were a real risk to the
financial stability of the country and
that we didn't well understand them and
the version of that this time
is that not understanding our industrial
supply chains in particular is proving
very difficult when we've been through
two years of turning our economy off and
turning it back on again and that is
then causing us a whole world of
problems which you illustrated very
very neatly obviously the uk is unusual
in that the economic change we're going
through
is the ones that other big developed
countries are going through which is net
zero plus covid
and we are adding to that the big change
that brexit
brings and i think stepping back and
thinking about the 2020s i think it is
really important to think about it in
the way you set out because this is not
just oh can we please get back to some
kind of vague normal after these crisis
it's about recognizing that the 2020s is
an era of unusual economic change as
brexit covid net zero all happen at once
and that does bring new economic
challenges understanding changes to
these supply chains understanding how
some kinds of workers are going to be
asked to make bigger changes in their
lives than we're used to because i know
everyone says oh you know change has
been speeding up for decades that
actually isn't true
it's actually we've been seeing less
change in most aspects of our economy
over recent decades and i think that's
why the next decade is a particularly
big challenge for us because a lot of
change is coming
thank you okay that's that's fascinating
to us and i'm glad glad to hear that i
wasn't talking total rot there the
audience here will be very reassured to
get your expert take uh on that and
thank you very much for appearing at big
ideas live thank you torsten bell from
the resolution foundation there
uh from london now i i just want to
finish off by by saying that you know as
torsten was was saying
understanding this stuff is going to be
really important for for all of us
we
are you know at the forefront of trying
to explain this stuff but the reason
that we're trying to come and talk to as
many people as possible is that we think
this is not necessarily a well developed
and well understood
part of the way the economy actually
fits together and genuinely the
government doesn't either i know people
within number 10 within the treasury who
are only beginning now to try to piece
together those maps i was talking about
right then it's not about having maps
like that so you can intervene it's
about having maps so you can understand
i mean you know good intervene if you
want to but it's about having maps so
you can understand what is going on
what's coming down the line what is the
impact going to be of decarbonisation
what's the impact going to be of brexit
our intelligence of this is really quite
primitive at the moment and so the more
we can try to understand that the better
we're going to understand the economy
which is why you know random as it is i
think that we need more maps now later
on uh my colleague sam washington's
gonna be talking to mark carney it's
gonna be really
interesting given his part uh obviously
in global
affairs at the moment he was obviously
central bank governor uh in the uk
after that now he's gone on uh to an
environmental role where he is looking
at the financing uh when it comes to
carbon when it comes to climate change
uh in cop so oh samuel behind me thank
you sam sam's here good morning
everybody i'm samantha washington i'm a
news presenter at sky news sometime uh
business presenter and climate show
presenter as well uh thank you very much
ed there ed of course our economics
editor our data editor and sky news's
resident geek as well